today jose leonarde lives in mannheim
it's an important location for the
chemical industry and could be the ideal
workplace for him but the 42 year old
isn't happy he can't find a job even
though chemists are in demand in the
region
it looks as though there's something in
my paperwork
something little in my resume maybe
that's standing in the way
something in his paperwork
so far not a single company has invited
him for a job interview
jose leonardi turned to a counselor for
help
he's not about to give up
mariam
is familiar with this case
his degree in biochemistry is already
recognized in germany
jose leonardi is qualified to work but
the paperwork often gets in the way when
it comes to foreigners like him
of course they're disadvantaged they
can't compete with the others if an
employer says he can't deal with the
translated documents from country x then
he's going to opt for a german applicant
who can produce a document with a german
stamp on it
has worked on hundreds of such cases
each one as complicated as the next
the legal situation can also be
difficult most german states don't have
laws recognizing foreign academic
credentials
so shariat and her colleagues never know
how a case will turn out they often seem
to be decided arbitrarily
with the argument that the curriculum
doesn't correspond to the german one
and that work experience isn't
sufficiently documented
well for me that's just not convincing
first of all it isn't true
so it's annoying
it's bureaucracy and it's really
annoying
to hamburg now one of the federal states
that does have a law recognizing foreign
academic credentials
she's been working for two months as an
engineer
responsible for safety at a construction
site
when hamburg passed the law last august
gloyer jumped at the opportunity
now that my degree is recognized here i
also have the chance to work in germany
as an engineer
is she happy that things are going
better
yeah
yes of course of course
it's given me new opportunities
other perspectives
did it take a long time
the certification itself took about half
a year
but getting to that point took a little
longer
tatiana gloria has been in germany for
15 years she first did secretarial work
then worked as an assistant at the
construction company she was
overqualified and underpaid for the jobs
i think it's sad because the foreigners
or we foreigners who come here to
germany we already have an education
we're qualified and i think it's an
enrichment for germany
leonardi now wants to try to get a job
in research
in the research sector i'll try to
develop further in my career field
it doesn't look like he'll be getting a
job in the industrial sector but still
he wants to find a career in germany
you